welcome to our live now playing for a
pair of upcoming PlayStation titles the
first one is Helldivers on the ps4 this
is mark Rogers from Sony here marched
mark oh mark not March thanks for
swingin by we've also got Eric Tay
manning the twitch chat over oh alright
here we go let's jump back into it um
Helldivers for somebody who's never
heard of this game before what's it all
about the Helldivers are an elite
military force and they fight for super
earth which is set in the far future
which is under manage democracy it's a
little bit more authoritarian than we're
used to but we're fighting a several
groups of kind of vicious aliens that
are attacking the earth and so this is
my ship welcome to my ship I've just
gone through and selected the mission so
we're going to jump down the hell pods
here so everyone needs to pick a
helicopter there we go hey man Oh what
he's going to go through they have your
last help but then there we go I'm gonna
jump down into here all the missions
themselves are procedurally generated so
I'm going to go through and we're going
to select where we're going to go so I
think this one's pretty good it's going
to be we're going to protect a
particular area and then we're going to
try and get out of there okay so let's
go to the low down as you go through and
progress in the game you have access to
lots and lots of different load out so
if we go through to the primary weapon
here you can see I have a lot of
different weapons my suggestion is
because we've just done a lot this for
the demo you would stick with the ones
near the top and you can also see left
and right that you can actually get
different variants of those weapons and
my my favorite is the justice i'm going
to use those I like that these abilities
are called stratagems so much classier
than ability so the stratagems that's a
special class of help that you can cool
down during the game them to not only
help yourself but to help your teammates
as well and so I'm going to select
myself a few kind of key stratagems here
you know the player is itself is welcome
to go through and choose whatever you
want and that's kind of key tactic of
the
you know kind of we meet you mix and
match our stratagems to produce the best
effect so yeah just go through and
confirm at the bottom and we'll def rise
against needs to go down to the bottom
and there we go sorry quick Deborah had
it's always game get your head out of
the chat air okay sorry sit Liberty day
is celebrated alright and Jana okay so
we're going to answer the planet itself
I can we can all play with the fight
with the camera some next-level stuff
right there is a wiggling technology
alright so here we go so move around
using the analogs and you can also aim
with the right analog here I'm going to
pull up the map yes friendly fire is
always on so shall wear your hearing oh
yes I thought no no no you care for it's
going to be a very very short mission
the so we're going to be going over at
the top here this is where the I know I
know special which got me for pointing
my gun whisper Thunder so here we got
going oh so you do are two ish inspire
ok alright and then our one is reload
help me so you're going to need to
reload a lot ok I have appeared a row
started crawling alright so if you then
press square to get up yeah oh here we
go so remember to reload trying to clear
these out you can Oh someone shot me
that I'm not gonna say that was me I
myself I'm not going to say that wasn't
so if you hold down l1 ok this will
bring up a menu and the bottom the
bottom key on the menu itself will
actually allow you to enter a code that
will bring me back and so so if you
don't hold down hold it down and now
enter it on the d-pad so which code is
it that brings you back it's the bottom
one down there goes up down yeah that's
there we go do we go he could do it
there you go and now throw it with the
the fire button and you can see that
that's going to come down now stay clear
of those because when they come down
they could kill you if they you're
underneath them alright so i'm out i'm
back cooking game alright so great there
we go
guys I'm just gonna hide in the bushes
until you take care okay take cover get
a little too hard for me I need to cool
down all right so we're looking good so
here if we are in this area we're
actually automatically capturing this
area so our goal is to stay here as much
as possible oh is that with these drop
pods on the sky yeah so I'm going to go
through and bring in a turret to help us
so I'm going to throw tore it down here
all right let's get it let's have a look
and see where we are so we've got
another big group coming to from our
left here so here we go after day jerks
so be careful to stay clear of the
turret as well because it will also kill
you okay um yeah kill you so tell me
what in this game won't kill us um these
flowers yes well yeah the flowers won't
kill you it's a hostile environment and
you know you really have to work
together in order to survive and that's
where the joy of it comes it's not only
that your interaction with the game
itself it is your interaction with each
other and as you can see we're talking
amongst ourselves to try and coordinate
what we're doing we should really stay
clear and there near the there we go I
want a fire on it John so the game
itself is developed by arrowhead which
is best known for magicka oh and that's
really good so they really know this
space very yeah they know the kind of
like crazy cooperative kind of style
again yeah and so you know they put all
their joy into this into this game
itself i'm going to call in some more
ammo so if anyone is running low on ammo
I am so you can go through and pick that
up don't stand under it right there some
more coming in through here so that all
of your stratagems work on like a cool
down yes they do you know and actually
some of them are single-use so if I'm
calling in special weapons yeah you can
just press X and fix them up there
against that pixel up as well
go through i'm going to stain it here
and make sure we capture capture these
bows the other because so all the
missions that are that everyone plays in
campaign mode they contribute towards an
intergalactic war that's played over one
and a half months and tada the entire
community basically fights against the
aliens during this war if humanity
survives then the war begins again but
at a higher difficulty so the overall
game itself is based on the you know
kind of performance of the entire
community so it's a dynamic system okay
so we're very interested to see how that
how the [ __ ] you know kind of us so we
completed our objectives so good good
job us right and so we're going to go
through and trying to extract over here
so let's see what the best way of doing
that is follow me that's good actually
we could call down some some heavy armor
let me call down this and call down a
big laser here as well just to make sure
that we we survive as you can see where
we're going has quite a few enemies and
so I get to go through here oh alright
so someone actually actually can get
into the locked into the mech oh mine
mine oh so if you go around the back of
the Mac you can actually press X climb
into it that's good it drives a bit like
a boat but um you'll be good let me call
in any resurrection it's less cool even
you die about it i died from my own a
drop they say that you know who it was
it's ok you gave your life there we go
so we good so we're going to be let's go
down this way follow me ok thank you sir
that's it here we go so yeah if you want
to run a little faster just press down
on the analog unfortunate the guy in the
mech is stuck on that speed so that's
good so yeah we can let the mac deal
Oh cook you know how stare yeah yeah see
where we are now yeah we're so we're
coming up to it oh so I just told me
that you can help me out there John
that's good all right if you want me to
shoot him for killing you all do okay
that's iffy maybe I don't mind so I'm
going to call in the the extraction beam
and so that's going to extraneous in
about one and a half minutes and so we
just have to hold the fort and so we
call in another running over here and
also I got its got air strike you
diminishing my best not to call it down
right on top thank you oh yeah cool it
there yeah we go let's run away that's
it Oh beautiful
oh hey turret oh forgot you were gonna
do that okay cool nice granulation there
we go just good ok they're going to be
coming down from the bottom right Tori
should be able to deal with most of it
fantastic ok all right so yeah just ha
30 seconds to go so do most conditions
for maintaining those missions follow
this sort of the sort of format where
you fight a bunch of waves of enemies
move the next point find a little yes so
there's there's different objectives as
I say the the maps are procedurally
generated so you know kind of you know
where they're located and and you know
the types of environment that you're
actually on changes from from planet to
planet there's also a large number of
objectives so the type of objectives you
have to ask or people you have to
protect certain areas of you have to get
out the way otherwise it's not gonna
land on me all right there we go
primadonna Polly and then that there we
go and then people can get out Oh Josh I
I died so that's it we did it yeah play
for us let's get a good work team
success and then obviously as we go
through you can see the tally how we all
performed way eighty percent oh babe
thank you van not bad for everyone come
on the silver there we go it's great I
unlocked it everything so I XP progress
is rather high but at this point you
would actually be gay you know gaining
lots and lots of different weapons and
stratagems and be you know other
customizations for your character and so
yeah that's it alright cool should we
jump and do another mission you want to
go for it sure we can try a little one a
little harder yeah shot I think we can
do it alright let's leave a little bit
let's go all right let's see what we
gotta do oh let's let's try this one oh
how I read nice and I would be nice
let's go to us a
what's the read this one it's going to
be yeah nice and simple um yeah that's
right okay
so this is in a different type of
environment the snow does affect play so
the deeper the snow there slowed we're
going to be able to move I think we all
just lined up and if we differ as to get
to this part we're going to do is that
will start next an escort mission first
which is you know kind of theater a
train we're going to have to escort it
get it to its destination the enemies
are going to come in and try and stop it
now is the train gonna take friendly
fire as well yes everything takes for
any fire your objectives also take for
any fire so you can you know kind of
lose objectives just by destroying them
yourself alright alright so I'm gonna go
to my neck well sweet alright so i was
pretty pretty please with my laid out so
well they're going to be young American
experiencing so the auto-injector as far
as the perks the pokes are very
interesting you ought to inject her if
you get rendered incapacitated and
you're kind of on the ground calling
around the auto-injector will allow you
to get back up if you don't have that
then someone's going to have to come
over and help you and so that's going to
rely on other people helping you more
than perhaps they will in this game I
feel like you're warning it now that my
loadout is for air strikes Oh who's
ready all right it's good I go shotgun
that's right guy all right good I'm good
firm here mission starts in 18 alright
guys and we're gonna do a thing called
randomized and do one of those
one of these green ones there all right
that's it it's a the builders are
working progress okay let's see how
those before haha they're gonna go well
weirdo there's nothing gonna be no
friendly fire in this movie by the seat
of our pants kinda situation Joe the
tips are shown on during the loading
screen hey hey okay i'm using the camera
ya know I am there you go sit I liked
include many games
alright so it's a little darker even
more mysterious all right here we are
o.o who's got the shotgun we're gonna
have to be careful with that I've seen
disaster happened with the dude with the
shotgun you have to there we go oh this
one you have to shoot in the back it was
oh it I saw the snow this snuff is so
heavy what was the sound faster button
oh he's a down I'm down oh now another
way it's killed me get it away Oh guys
what I think I might be that splatter of
blood on the ground right now that's
good so someone call this in it's good
oh come on oh come on mo sang kho zing
so goin shut up i gotta lose all my
shotgun coolest car oh how do i do that
close in do the code press down l1 there
we go yeah that was good I did some
space oh wow that was bang there you go
no tell me the coal people in code yeah
are we getting to the side without doing
it dude yeah dude it's they have enough
load we got it out of our system right
that was our one failure we're gonna get
it now I guess I'm calling a
hundred-percent hundred-percent yeah
well Sam bishes I feel out of it yeah
everyone hit X there we got none of
those guys okay what was the what is the
call in command so then just just yeah
jump down the old pots so yeah if you if
you hold down a well one and it's the
you know kind of just just have a look
on the menu you'll see it as a pointy
people with the arrow pointing up yeah
that's okay yeah that's one okay so
let's color select we did so well with
that one let's do it again all right
does the buzzer call down if name is
multi layers down oh yeah all of us down
oh yeah so yeah if if three players
around and it's just one guy running
around real man then if he calls you
know kind of revive then everyone gets
revived where is that key individual at
the end is you know is very important
which
I'm going mech suit there we go worked
out well for me last time all right we
got a couple of mix as well so I can
fall out in it or if anyone needs it so
alright guys back on any sort of time
limit or is it just there it tell us
destroyed it some know it's there until
it's destroyed there is it will run out
of ammo and there is a special ammo pack
that you actually have to have in order
to restock it so I don't think anyone's
actually we don't stop that asteroids
it's one of the strategies so you know
if you run out of ammo just dispose a
bit in a in a good way yeah we're going
alright alright sweet reloading
reloading laughs
all right big ones coming so shoot it
from behind it's vulnerable only oh god
it's already chasing me shoot the red
but I'm on the wrong side of the red but
ya know it's killing my exosuit oh and I
think it may be killed me too that's
good we killed it great nice all right
now come in and help you do so up there
we go don't let me die today there we go
I'm seeing great real life oh oh I kylo
you kill it oh no it got me oh no oh
come on how is that one come on oh god
no no don't die don't die hey Carlos
come on okay oh no we go oh good yeah
killer someone show me oh no aw come on
I got him okay hope it's up that's great
all right I'm calling them in are we
good oh you did it too that's good how r
I got cool down it's okay go down on oh
so it's all right as long as you don't
kill me I know all right I'm cool you in
my second yeah look how I'm alive that's
all that matters all right so I'm get a
call you in thank you here we go Oh
watch out I just randomly through some
grenades oh now I'm down I'm down
somebody shot me and I'm down oh you
shocked yeah I don't know who picked the
shotgun but that was a real wild card
move no okay Oh God so you weren't
kidding about some of these missions
being really hard yeah real yeah the uh
yeah okay maybe let's do a medium
mission yeah okay let's try a medium
yeah yeah we got too confident yeah I
think maybe we kind of like
overcorrected from that first one that
was that was on us guys that we
apologize for that let's challenge you
know commit flight you've got to leave
something on the tape that's Joey
everyone press X there we go yeah all
right let's let's select something else
it's leave a little bit Jane's gonna
redeem himself on them yeah I'm your
knight use a shotgun you're not gonna
use the shotgun you can one hundred
percent less shark killed in Utah yeah
you killed a lot of people that time
shotgun with you let's try this one
bellatrix bellatrix and um look at a
mission oh we got here oh yeah that one
looks good does the game have some sort
of a story mode or is it kind of the
missions that we've been kind of going
through so far so yeah the you know you
know the overarching arc of the story
itself is your fight against the aliens
themselves and that's played out over as
I say about one and a half to two months
and so you know kind of you know it's
really the community working together
let me select the drop zone here we yeah
let's fight for some oil yeah as people
their space oil space I don't get this
we space what do you think powers that
mech suits massive space oil okay now no
breaker this time let's look this is
enough I'm gonna go
menu gun turret that's good I'll keep
one air strike should I go shotgun
calling from most expensive goes
expensive gun this is my power are you a
narc though I'm doing art thrower oh
really okay it might be a short mission
I use this that's right the late game
I'm good about this morning i got an arc
thrower one of the seas yeah all right
okay here we go we knew this all right
it's really good feeling good aah the
thing that matters most is that Maxwell
doesn't have the shotgun at this time
what we're all bio Maxwell took the
shotgun what we all took shotgun oh yeah
it'll be perfect it would all cancel
each other out and we just go back to
back well let's just go back to back
well I'll go back to back yeah it's a
locational awareness yeah that's the
issue yeah we're gonna be like we're all
fighting in on on the same space you
know be like forest and Bubba in the
jungle just yeah leaning on each other's
backs for support all right okay let's
put up some I'm gonna put up a turret
are we defending something yeah we gonna
this I'm gonna put up an hour the turret
as well over here all right there again
shoots lightning badly is so the more
you the more you hold down the trigger
on that weapon the more powerful it
becomes oh yeah oh we now got this guy
all right oh yeah oh I ran over why
should it Charlie I waiting for we got
him oh no oh Holly's me to say not me oh
don't worry you're not save it I need
you to call me in somebody he's calling
all over soon somebody grab that mech
suit there we go I'll grab the mayor too
I'm gonna call some ammunition in as
well there we go sweet all right
oh what the turn is shooting my mech
suit oh stop come on huh well put that
turret there that was me ah the captain
okay i would i'd like to say that I did
put the turret down before you put mason
bees Jeremy that's it so this is what
that's it I think helps in thank God I
said oh great thank you someone killed
me on our team we should try and
complete the objective yeah so I'll go
through and try and complete the
objective here we go Oh Oh No there we
go so can we stand up here no Terry go
Terry took me out again charging up this
one pretty heavily guys you better watch
out all right listen okay all right let
me get some more ammunition if you start
running out ah right so I'm gonna start
oh ok oh no oh yeah that was good I
don't know all right I've got cool down
so it's kinda so dang so we're just
gonna have to we're just gonna have to
hold our own sometime you help me don't
let it overheat otherwise you're gonna
be out of there ok yeah so gonna run try
to run know that you can do Oh
I really thought you had that one I
really good if you wore his lucky [ __ ]
teamwork could use so see how we did
will refinement Wow oh yeah we got ten
percent that other time there you go
person so does the game all couch co-op
own there's no I'm so glad you brought
that the so yeah you can play couch
co-op two to four players there is a
single player mode you can also play
remote court okay and any combination of
the two so you know a couple of people
you can play on cows you can play with
your friends remotely it's also
available on ps3 ps4 and Vita and it's
cross-play across all platforms as well
cool so you're not kind of yeah you can
play in any combination that's great
sounds good